[Musique]
et ce soir il ya une personne qui a
voulu déclarer son amour à quelqu'un sur
ce plateau
et oui est ce qu'on peut voir cette
personne
s'il vous plaît cette personne on va la
découvrir lé ton ombre chinoise
jean luc alphand nombreux chinoise c'est
farrell il vient pour et nohra
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
déclarer son amour à quelqu'un sur le
plateau alors là on rigole mais je le
dis dans un an ce taux
je pense que ça va être plus compliqué
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un dans le public
qui pensent reconnaître cette personne
ce que quelqu'un pour se reconnaître
cette personne non comme sa personne on
va donner à la personne de parler de
dire une petite phrase allez-y ça fait
25 ans que je connais la personne en
question
ça fait 25 ans qu'il connaît la personne
en question n'a pas pris un peu plus de
100 langues
sk quelqu'un qui reconnaît cette
personne dans le public non autour de la
table non personne
il va il va reparler
on vous écoute j'avais préparé un petit
message pour la personne du boulot lit
ça fait plus de vingt cinq ans que l'on
se connaît que l'on se côtoie et que
l'once a pris vos rêves
les années ont passé et nous nous sommes
un peu éloigné mais si j'ai sur mon
compte du long gardoise le lien qui nous
unit ne s'est jamais briser et si les
longs discours ne sont pas mon fort ma
présence ce soir
et ces mots qui viennent du coeur
devrait te prouver sans grands efforts
que j'ai été et reste ton plus grands
admirateurs
alors moi ils vont me faire chialer
est ce que quelqu'un reconnaisse cette
personne s'est il alors voyez un truc
bizarre si toi non non il ya un truc
bizarre parce que je sais et doit
c'est pourquoi mais j'ai des battements
d'choeur c'est oui et 1 c
et quand il s'est mis de profil oui il
peut se remettre de profits et parce
qu'on peut remettre prévoit remettre de
profil monsieur mais c'est mon fils
pensez que c'est votre fils il s'appelle
comment votre fils il s'appelle
guillaume est ce que vous appelez
guillaume oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
obama
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
below s'il vous plaît ils ont un petit
message pour isabelle mais venez là les
chéris mais guillaume evin qui les fait
il est hyper millau et guillaume vous
avez un message pour votre maman qu'on
aime fort et u10 a pété un toulouse
alors si ça paraît tellement mignon
c'est pour toi de le faire banqueroute
je sais je sais pas quoi dit alain
crevet par les équipes ont appelé hier
c'était un peu compliqué mais du coup
j'ai eu les occasions pour pour venir te
voir parce que je déteste les médias
celle inverse de mathieu quand je
l'amenais aux césars il s'emmerder comme
un rat mort il s'est endormi à table et
tout est donc ils détestent l'immédiat
il regarde là ils regardent l'émission
voir ce que je dis sur lui merci à mais
ça ne vous aime bien bravo si ça me
branche sis à bâle en touche c'est donc
tous vraiment beaucoup de millions avec
la chose à vous dire c'est vrai que
c'est il nous a donc se regardent pas
masi tout simplement je t'aime fabulous
cours
des beaux titres
la série avec sarkozy ça parce que tu
partes souvent lui qui me dit tu vois
pas et bat guillaume items fort et
voulais te dire ce soir
merci est comme ça merci
[Applaudissements]